it is so painful that janapanishi's
outstanding chance to win the fide World
Championships opening game slip through
his fingers against dingler in the
pressure of the fide World Championship
is legendary an experience is often a
decisive Factor while there is no
defending champion because Magnus
Carlsen the greatest player of all time
has decided not to defend his title the
previous Challenger nepo has the edge
and experience and he leveraged it to
Serious Advantage with excellent opening
choices that kept ding Under Pressure
the powerful 27 Queen F4 was nearly
winning as nepo invaded dings queenside
and he was poised to begin mopping up
all of the queen side pawns then a few
moves later nepo aired with 31 F4
creating weaknesses in his own Camp
stiff resistance by Dean find it off
tricky threats and time trouble
ultimately securing a draw in 49 moves
now ding will get the white pieces in
game two and time to calm his nerves
which is why